you probably heard about McDonald's new
mascot it's kind of new it's at least
new here in the United States his name
is happy let's look at happy
this guy's happy that is a scary freakin
mascot that's real when I saw this first
I thought it was one of those stories
that you see that you go no that can't
possibly real because that looks scary
to me happy according to the McDonald's
press release is about bringing more fun
and excitement to kids meals including
eating wholesome food like low-fat
yogurt okay now we can we can come back
to us happy just when you look at happy
do you feel happy what is the emotion
that happy brings out you well I will
say this in my personal hell thousands
of those characters will be charging
towards me with Pharrell's happy playing
on repeat you know the thing is
McDonald's will never be cool and it
will never be healthy they're trying to
like do this new thing where they're
like I've seen some ads where they're
trying to appeal to hipsters recently
I've seen this this looks like some
graphic designer in college was in their
room and like put together this like
very amateur looking graphic to me it's
not it doesn't you know symbolise
anything that is like cool and fresh and
whatever right so I want to get to the
cool and fresh thing but first just
unhappy himself here's the thing how did
they do this I've been happy I've never
been that happy you never have never
been remotely as happy the happy meal
and yet there's a they're replacing all
the food they're either giving you like
apple wedges in the Happy Meal and maybe
that extra amount of sugar is what puts
them over the top maybe I I do it
doesn't look like something
professionally it looks like clipart yes
it looks like something a comedy show
would make in order to make fun of a
happy meal type mascot yeah is there
something deeply psychological going on
with McDonald's that they have to do
something that bad and over-the-top
because of exactly what your point is
which is they're trying to be something
they're not
so they can't authentically make
something that would feel right I really
think anything the words deep and
psychological
cannot be associated with McDonald's at
this point I'm trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt here oh I don't
think they deserve any benefits the
doubt yeah definitely yeah definitely
the doubt give them as much of that as
possible it's crazy the eyeballs on that
thing the fact that I mean look at it
it's its eyes are permanently filled
back though happy back up there
it's very skinny it has an enormous hat
athletic show itself is very inviting I
feel like I can cozy up in there for
hours oh right like the dontist yeah
look at those teeth liber8
the veneer teeth the eyes peeled back
the skinniness with you it's Bruce
Jenner it's kind of there's no and the
elbows like eat happy meals and you will
have no bones in your arm you want no
bones in just an incredibly large torso
yeah it's just so this this kind of
gives me positive reinforcement that
people have caught on to McDonald's cuz
when I was that when I was a kid we
would eat Happy Meals all the time
because that was just what you did in
the eighties E and we'd have we'd have
birthdays parties there remember the
birthday breakfast at McDonald's with
the pancakes oh good my Incredibles yeah
and then and now people are on to them
and they have to resort to these very
strange things and it's almost like
someone who is the age of Ray Kroc was
like what a kids like cartoon give them
one use a computer so that's what it is
what you started this by saying that we
all are on to the the thing that they're
doing now so it has to be over-the-top
they show us hipsters everyone
everyone's always fit in their
commercials also which if you go to
McDonald's generally the people aren't
that fit they're not that happy and all
that so it's like they just keep
doubling down right to push the image
yeah I think so I mean you know you
never want to run into someone you know
and I McDonald's it's true like it's not
a social gathering spot it's not the
Starbucks
of fast food at all but those
commercials were all those hip
good-looking people are like sending
fries to the girl down there and then
they like until I mean you know I'm
totally gonna send you some fries later
I want to know you don't want to know
where is the old-school posse of Ronald
where are they where's murder Hamburglar
yeah like Hamburglar yeah I feel like
shooting heroin in a corner somewhere
like they're like they've given up on
life you know you got fired from
McDonald's what's that everything so
offensive these days the grimace I'm
sure would offend
purple people or what the hamburger
people eat at McDonald's all the time
are the shape of grimace so they know
what I remind people right yeah the
Hamburglar you know criminals you guys
do realize that the commenters are gonna
say we're elitist bastards for making
fun of McDonald's and they would be
correct yeah yeah you know I I applaud
McDonald's recent attempts to like put
lettuce and things you know there's like
a green lettuce now as opposed to like
the iceberg version they used to have
right and they offer a grill a grilled
chicken read all the photos just offer
grilled chicken branding to be pressed
into other cooked otherwise cooked meat
yeah yeah why don't they just do the
honest thing and just sort of admit what
they are cuz I think that why don't they
just double down on that instead of the
lie that somehow this is healthy or good
for you or fun or appie
why don't they get look we know this is
fast food like they're not tricking
anybody wouldn't a little honesty be
nice I would go to McDonald's more often
if there was like just like some
overweight guys yeah I really sad and
depressed I'm giving up on life but I'm
gonna enjoy me a Big Mac one more time
I'd be like yeah okay you know sign me
up and what I also like is when you the
Olympics comes around all the Olympians
are sponsored by McDonald's and the
thing is those are the only people who
can eat McDonald's yeah because those
are the people who can eat 5,000
calories a day and still maintain their
physique cuz they're working out all the
time that's funny you know i remember
the old remember the Larry Bird Michael
Jordan commercial bounced off the
backboard and everything everything like
these guys would never eat McDonald's
during the playoffs cuz it's not like
the Olympians where they have to keep
eating just for whatever right like
they're they'll take the money from
McDonald
you